imagine you were able to shrink the Sun
to the size of a basketball at that
point the earth would be reduced to the
size of a sesame seed that's how massive
our star is but what if this fiery ball
of gas and plasma wasn't the biggest
thing in our solar system would our
planet still orbit the Sun or with the
Sun rotate around the mass of Earth what
would happen to our planetary neighbors
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Sun was smaller than the
earth it would take the equivalent of
1.3 million earths to fill up the volume
of the Sun it's so big that it makes up
over 99% of the mass of our entire solar
system it only looks small from Earth
because it's a hundred and fifty million
kilometres away if hypothetically the
Sun was smaller than the earth the earth
would be uninhabitable and the Sun well
this massive star may no longer be a
star in the universe size matters and so
does distance it just so happens that
the earth is close enough to the Sun
that it doesn't freeze over like Mars
it's also far enough away that it
doesn't get scorched like Venus we're
fortunate to be in the sun's habitable
zone this means that the size of our
planet the size of the Sun and the
distance between the two of us is what's
made it possible for life to evolve here
on earth what would happen if the Sun
was smaller than our planet a star's
mass determines its color and
temperature bigger stars are hotter and
bluer while smaller ones are cooler and
redder the Sun is a white star not as
big as a supergiant and not as small as
a red dwarf star you might think that by
making it smaller in size it would just
turn into a red dwarf with a smaller
habitable zone but that's not the case
by definition a star whether it's a
supergiant or a red dwarf is only a star
when there's thermonuclear fusion in its
core how small can stars get well we
haven't measured too many red dwarfs at
this point but the smallest one we came
across has a mass of 10 Earth's that's
very close to the theoretically
necessary size of a star to sustain that
fusion anything smaller than
Earths wouldn't be a star anymore but
rather a cold and dark stellar remnant
if for any reason the Sun shrank smaller
than the earth this shrunken Sun
wouldn't have the mass to create fusion
and would burn out completely our solar
system would lose its only star since
the Sun is the source of gravity that
keeps us all in orbit all planets the
earth included would float away into
space in search of another anchor that's
no happy ending for life on Earth let's
try this again this time let's make the
earth bigger than the Sun while the Sun
size remains the same Earth's mass would
be at least three hundred and thirty
three thousand times bigger than it is
now
a planet that big would generate enough
heat and pressure in its core to become
a star itself of course there would be
no life left on this hot star but here's
a cool thing our solar system would have
not just one but two suns it would
become a binary star system with two
stars orbiting around each other and
planets circling them both in either
scenario life on Earth would have no
chance to survive but life could
possibly evolve on other planets or even
the moon about a third of all stellar
systems we found so far are binary or
multiple ones some of them even have
stable habitable zones how cool would it
be to live in a real-life Tatooine with
two suns in the sky that's a question
for another what-if
[Music]